i love the little things about you
i love your home cooking
i just love your silent pictures
i love new york you know why of course
it's open all night
[Music]
i remember when that aired that classic
ad from the early 1980s beckoned all of
america to come to visit new york with
the summer travel season here the effort
to draw tourists and their vacation
dollars now includes all 50 states and
that includes some that acknowledge
right up front
are not such an easy sell
barry peterson has the story
the people of nebraska take great
pleasure in things that are a little
shall we say unusual
unorthodox
atypical
selling nebraska to tourist is about
marketing odd
lucky for you
we invent things to do like when we
realized a livestock tank would float
and when the campaign started four years
ago it came with an equally odd last
line nebraska honestly it's not for
everyone
irresistible to late night host stephen
colbert do you know what else has got to
be a tough job
nebraska tourism commissioner john ricks
is executive director of the actual
nebraska tourism commission who helped
invent the ads do you think you
encouraged people to pay more attention
because you said to some of them maybe
they wouldn't care there were a number
of professional perceptions out there
and they were basically flat and boring
nothing to do
fly over country dusty planes and then
you basically tell them the real story
which is the truth that there's a lot of
fun things to do here adventure is out
there come find it in the land of great
faces and great places touting tourism
stretches from the great plains
start spreading the new
to the great cities in a tv commercial
war between the states
new york new york
it's time
to let yourself explore
the wide open beauty of florida so when
florida sells big vistas texas says it
doesn't need wide-angle lenses because
its big vistas are the real thing hold
on
you don't need to use camera magic to
make this vacation look exciting it
actually is
[Music]
california markets flood on the sun with
hollywood's special effects while
mississippi encourages a serious look at
civil rights history
[Music]
[Music]
when the pandemic hit and tourism hit
just about zero wyoming marketed its
wide open spaces as the space we all
needed
and when it was over trust las vegas to
flip the fun switch back on big time
and travel is back to booming says
torrey emerson barnes from the u.s
travel association
91
of of american travelers
have a trip planned in the next six
months
have you been to
nebraska no but as i said now that i saw
the
the new campaign i i might have to get
out there back in nebraska this summer's
new ads prove tongue-in-cheek is selling
better than ever shocking fact not every
corn husker grows corn over a million
nebraskans live in places we like to
call cities where we enjoy amenities
like electricity running water zoos
gardens the arts did people really think
that nebraska was only farmland and no
cities
absolutely and we had to be unexpected
edgy
and you know even risky to to some
extent
but it's working working so well that
their four million dollars a year spent
on marketing helps generate a quarter
billion dollars in state and local tax
revenue
nebraska are you okay
seriously seems like you could use a
vacation to not nebraska
thanks steven but in a state used to
being laughed at
they're laughing all the way to the bank
we know some people won't take the time
but if you're someone who will
odds are
you're going to like it here
[Music]
nebraska
for cbs saturday morning barry peterson
denver
not even barry went to nebraska but i've
been there i've been to nebraska and
they have electricity in nebraska so i'm
going to have to go to nebraska now i i
love that idea though find the other
things in your state and there is
something we travel so much you know
this everywhere you go they're somewhere
fast absolutely absolutely and think of
these ad campaigns through pure michigan
and tim out which is so true so
successful so long virginia's for lovers
what's really wild and wonderful like
this is bigger that's good yeah you have
a nice watch enough tv
you know all the states hey throw some
nice drone shots and a good soundtrack
and i'm there